let's go next to Dev from Syracuse New
York Dev welcome to the David packman
show what's on your mind today
hi David
I've got a question for you sure can you
hear me all right I can hear you fine
all right well uh Syracuse I don't know
if you know much about Syracuse Upstate
New York uh it is a pretty mixed place
but probably a little more leaning to
the right okay in general uh lots of
suburbs uh and and Country farmered
areas
um so I would describe myself as a
progressive independent and I know
titles are a difficult thing but um I
recently became a firearm owner okay and
uh I was wondering um
what your opinion is on personal firearm
use in the context of a tool that might
be used for some things in the future I
kind of look at it like an EpiPen right
it's something that I never want to use
I'm not really a hunter but I want to
have it available in a situation that
may occur where it would be useful well
listen you bring up a really interesting
point and I've had a I have a lot of
friends who are progressive gun owners
many many many friends
I've opted never to talk on the show
about whether or not I own firearms like
I've made it clear I support certain
rules and I've said we have a second
amendment but we we have to do something
about the gut like people know my but
I've sort of like stopped short of
saying exactly like what I do or don't
have just because it doesn't there
doesn't seem to be any advantage to that
and if I said exactly what I do or don't
have I just don't know there's any wind
there but one thing that is very very
um compelling to me is
any scenario that is a hypothetical
scenario
that comes up in which the right Wingers
have all or most of the guns that
doesn't sound good even if I think we
are much better off reducing the number
of firearms out there by 95 percent
uh and and like for example even if we
could limit them to people who
demonstrate that they're for hunting use
or it's for target shooting and you keep
it at the range in a safe that's there
or if you can demonstrate an actual need
for self-defense not the vague I've got
50 like okay maybe that would be the the
ideal thing reduce the number of guns
out there by 95 we don't have that
situation and therefore I don't really
love the idea of the right Wingers
having all the guns and what you're
talking about the these contingency
scenarios
make a lot of sense to me in terms of a
motivation to say I want to own some
firearms you know New York is uh I don't
know all of the gun laws across the
country but it seems like New York is
one of the most uh
strict gun laws uh areas in any of the
states and I definitely think that uh
that's a good thing uh running into
roadblocks when you're trying to
purchase a firearm uh even as a you know
a safe uh normal citizen so to speak I
think is is a good thing it shouldn't be
easy to get a firearm I agree and listen
in New York City I'll just say it this
way
I have experienced you know I I it could
be for friends I have experienced the
New York City process for the handgun
permit and it's not easy but it is
possible and if you do it right then
it's a permit that you're able to get
let me ask you just this one uh related
question and I'll let you go I had seen
an idea that I think could appeal to the
right wing as well after they get over
the fact that uh you know it's a change
which is difficult for them to process
um it was essentially uh like a an
evolving gun license where for each
firearm that you wanted to own or even
just fire if you had to qualify on that
particular firearm and therefore that
license would almost be like uh like
collecting it would tap into that kind
of psyche of collecting and you could
that's a super interesting idea that's a
super interesting commercial commercial
pilots have to qualify on the planes
that they fly I think that's a super
interesting idea Dev from Syracuse great
to hear from you very very interesting